actually I have a question is that okay
yeah all right and this has led to do
with weed control but I've been thinking
about this in the back of the room and I
and if I don't ask it I'm going to feel
bad because I got to leave to go to
another meeting so soil organic soils
the ph is going to be best near the
surface where you're working the soil as
you go deeper how does that pH change
and when you pop that that a culture
through the plow pan and you're thinking
about roots going down how well do those
roots grow as they go deeper into the
soil and especially if they grow in
below the plow pan and you're into soils
that I would imagine a fairly low pH is
down there how does it all work or as
water uptake all you're really getting
out of that are you not getting
nutrients from that far down I'm just
curious about the deeper soils and lower
pH as you go down maybe I should have
paid attention when i was in college but
but i don't know the answer to that
question it up to anyone else that has
some experience and thinking about this
but as we when we have us up we are
getting better foraging of ribs deeper
in the soil for news they're gonna read
anything about issues around the change
in PH with the depth of the soil profile
because that the roots are filling up
that whole volume that's all that's been
disturbed until they get the improvement
in the root growth and the improved
bigger of the crop in its ability to
forge has been the benefits of doing
this song till system so i didn't know
if there was any other comments or
observations from other growers that
have been doing this my on yes go ahead
we've had several cases where we have
gone through the palm tanks and got down
into some ph of 5.1 or something and it
is absolute death on corn they may come
up there going to be 68 inches tall
water runs fast
get down to the leader of a subside
they're toast bring it what about she's
done the same thing so deep tilling is
can be death Phil prop if they get down
into a pH is not appropriate for the
crop that is you want to grow we had a
tremendous example of this in
Pennsylvania in New Hampshire this year
and basic grind agronomy 101 you can't
grow in PH 5.000% in those appeals no he
still wants to use the system but he's
not going too deep till till against the
pH changed in the whole soul soil
profile he's going to be putting his
nitrogen shallow and you know Tillich
will only be 10 inches deeper 12 you
know with a stripped ill so he's not
messing around done in that low pH Dolph
pro-reactive with your liming so that
you keep putting it on if you're going
to need it because it takes longer to
get down there right because the pH you
know you got to use a cornell ph get to
take a pinch of soil from two feet deep
or 17 inches deep or whatever and see if
it's you know appropriate for the crop
if it gets way low then either you know
till and grove shell or or something
else Grosso Mills we haven't talked
about sampling soil deep for pH doesn't
take long and it's cheap for a pH
kitchen pocket you own a soil probe you
can tell what it is at two inches 10
inches 20 inches but we haven't talked
about it we've talked about with no-till
doing shelter
regular PHS and on the muck because of
real low pH stuff we're starting to do
sampling below 12 inches sonic some
bucks we'll have a pH of 7 jul they go
down into calcium where the Queen
decayed too but it's something that we
need to consider is is the pH testing if
if you suspect something I guess right
ask the plan I know I have a question
for you when you took the soil samples
from the field you guys trialed this
past season how deep did you go on that
because that field has been heavily
lined for years the only thing I did
different was the last three years it's
been a super heavy cover crop on it that
I've trying to build the organic better
in a field is that what drove that pH
down salopes that thing came back like
59 or something and it should there's no
way it should be reading even close to
that great yeah I don't I think that we
sampled that soil fairly shallow for the
soil health test I don't think that we
did a full 12 inch depth on that but we
can do that again this year would heavy
cover crop over extended period of time
closet to be that low on the surface I
wouldn't think so this is jude and in
massachusetts yeah i have a couple of a
little bit of experience to share with
you on this um generally with with
reduced tillage you want to pay strict
attention to you to your liming
practices you need to do it more
frequently regularly we had a grower
that has been using his own till for a
while and he was trying to zone till one
year and then leave his arm he was
preparing beds and this was for being
production preparing raised beds with
them to try to combat some disease
problems and he was leaving these beds
for 34 years and over that time period
his ph would dive throughout the entire
field even though he would would
topically apply lime
if not every year every other year what
we had him do was come back in and
rebuild those beds razon till every
single year to solve the problem and
that seems to have turned he turned his
plantings around I think you can run
into some problems with this for
instance Gary sweet out in Ohio does
zone tilling in the same slots every
single year he well he's own tills first
and then he uses a multivator over the
top so he's just basically stripped ill
and over those same zones and replanting
in those areas and before he came to New
England to talk I asked him I said are
you having problems with your with us
acidification going on in those slots
because in New England with our soils if
you did that and applied some nitrogen
fertilizers in that slot year after year
your your pH would really dive in just a
short period of time I don't know what
happens with Ohio so maybe they have to
solve this oil instead of line them so
maybe he's getting away with it that way
he said he claims his crops improve in
every single year but what I suggested
that he do was go back into those slots
and run some soil pH test both shallow
and deeply and also between the rows to
see if he's having problems with pH
starting to dive in those slots so there
are considerations that growers will
have to think about when they get into
this type of things I think with the
with the deep zone till as opposed to a
no-till system you do have the
opportunity to move some lime deep in
the soil obviously it's not throughout
the entire soil profile in the field
it's only in the slots that you're
disturbing on those particular years
which again reinforces the fact that you
need to apply the line regularly Thank
You Jude do we have other comments on
sort of lining strategies or what people
been doing in their zone tillage and
their deep zone killers George or Lynn
yes
okay well I'm with lime and reduced or
no challenge I think the use of the air
way too much tool if you put spread lime
on the surface and then airway it
relatively aggressively you know that
rainfall will move that lime into that
top six inches of the soil fairly well
if we want to avoid you know tillage and
your full tillage we've seen that be
fairly effective that particular field I
knew that you guys tested that's the
field I'd dump the linemen and the piles
that we work out of so that's always the
first one to get done over here that
one's never been skipped and that's just
been broadcast treated with line but
there's been years that was done like
three years in a row with high cal lime
that's why when I got that soil test on
again this cannot be right you know with
all that lime it's been applied to that
thing but I don't know i I just the only
thing I done different was it was three
years of continuous rye I was trying to
just do a little testing and see if it
would help my fight a through problem if
I planted nothing there but right so the
sum of the Rye had never had the last
couple years I hadn't even taken their
eye off I just dissed it down let it
reseed so I come up a really thick that
stuff was such a heavy heavy side this
year I to spray that with Roundup a long
time because it was it was you know it's
a lot thicker cropping you know any
plants way more than three bushel per
acre seed so I didn't know if that would
have caused it or not but it was it was
really nice loamy soil when I worked it
up this year I mean it I think I I don't
know what I did as far as organic matter
I was kind of shocked that they didn't
come up either with the amount of
biomass I put down on it over three year
period I know I make a comment about the
line the dude was talking about one of
the things that we learned weight or we
were told way 15 years or so ago when i
started was to move the deep his own
builder strips every year in other words
the grain farmer grow will grow a
30-inch row and then the second year
you're still in the middle
and whether it's sweet corn or
vegetables or what move it over to the
side because I've been spreading line
regularly but every year I tell a little
different place I never go on the same
row and so in those Coulter's on the
back of that tiller or till and three or
four inches deep to make that mound and
so you're working six to eight inches of
ground work the linemen every time you
do it and so if you move every year and
don't put your rule in the same place
over a three or four year period you're
going to end up till in the whole field
and that's making I'm not having a
problem with pH even though I zone till
I use own tillage every year I don't
have a problem with it getting lower and
lower pH because I could spread a tunnel
line every say once every three years
and then over that period of time I work
the whole field once and it makes it it
keeps working it into soil so that's the
secret that I think is not to put your
row on the same place every year there's
other reasons for in terms of soil
compaction and other reason not to do it
but the lining is one of them I know we
have a question here on Long Island
about the lime if anybody might be able
to address it okay I have a question in
regard to the effect that compost might
have on the ph in the soil I recently
applied approximately 25 tons of compost
that tested about seven-and-a-half pH
and I not sure whether that would have
any long-term or short-term impact on
the soil pH as wondering if anyone could
address that um how many years have you
been doing this in a row to we we have
done some work or we we haven't used
that high of a rate but in other work
and other observations the pH does tend
to go up slightly over time with heavy
rates of compost
you haven't heard that but you can't a
shot I'm out and concentrated it looks
on the field 25 times of a material that
it can in depending on what the source
of the material was and what the source
of accomplice was will have a different
but the food stock was thank the elderly
grass and brush okay the other thing
that you want to consider with this is
the organic matter in your soil existing
as was mentioned earlier there was a
problem up in New Hampshire when they
were deeper flying the night ran for
sweet corn and what we determined that
problem to be was that the organic
matter levels were extremely low in
those soils it was a sandy Merrimack
soil and basically it didn't have the
buffering capacity so when the when the
all of nitrogen was applied all at once
what was happening was the pH in that
area was was crashing over a point it
was dropping from six point two down to
4.8 as low as four point eight other
areas of the field didn't have any
problem so environment so so the more
you put that compost down the more you
can have buffering capacity in your soil
and you shouldn't have problems with
that type of a pH drop a sudden pH drop
and basically that's the recommendation
we came up with for the grower in New
Hampshire was to start adding some
organic matter to his soil so that he
could try to get back to that deep
deeply applied on nitrogen just to
comment on Jude I believe that farmer of
New Hampshire the pH sat down at 17
inches was five point water so my rogue
I didn't do the sampling myself so I'm
not sure exactly if he did any any deep
deep sampling but even on the surface
in six inch deep samples he had low low
PHS I believe that phone call come out
of the blue at a meeting in Pennsylvania
and the I thought from the conversation
that the crop grew to be six seven eight
inches tall and then the roads got down
into that nasty ph 5.0 and then that's
when they had it south of died is this a
temporary pH crash because the pumpkins
I had planted on this field where this
ph was so low were beautiful I mean it
was just a massive green everything was
fine but I had broadcast 100 pounds of
nitrogen with my herbicide I don't know
is that possible that's what caused at
ph crash boy can't answer that question
I know the pumpkins are a little more
tolerant to a low pH situation than the
sweet coins going to be that's one of
the questions we asked when you answered
for Keith during the questioning period
but I can't tell you exactly what caused
it I believe that that sweet corn in New
Hampshire that the nitrogen was placed
about 7 inches deep from the soil
surface so that too there was a constant
you know most surely there's a rule of
eight nitrogen should be at least eight
inches from the seat if it's going to be
below it and I think that that nitrogen
was placed shell off with my
conversation with the grower and I
wonder if that didn't have play into
this whole mess this possibility i guess
i guess you have to answer you ask
yourself how critical the last inches
right at this point we are into the
section of our video comments or we were
talking about fertility and we've just
moved into that quite naturally now one
thing that we started to allude to is
the use of deep place nitrogen in the
slot and i didn't know if there were
some growers online here that have been
trying this and would like to share some
of their
experiences and what prop they've been
doing this with will start in western
New York and I'm sure enter George if
you've been using deep place than or not
no I haven't done any deep placement cuz
I'm growing all my sweet corn and
pumpkins now following killed alfalfa so
i don't need the nitrogen so don brandon
is the only one that I've had any
experience with and I'd be doing what he
does if I needed the nitrogen but I
haven't needed any so at this point I
haven't done anything except put the
nitrogen on with the planner I haven't
either okay I haven't tried to get
either it's something I want to
experiment with and the tomatoes and
things like that but just not set up to
do it and haven't taken the time to
build anything to try to place it down
there mm-hmm how about anybody else I
believe Joe brightly and Casey Kuhn did
use some deep end with the squash and
cabbage this past year and they saw
really pretty good results with both of
those I believe yeah mmhmm yeah in our
own work we've been using we've been
looking and comparing the basically a
deep placed and with all of the nitrogen
applied at the beginning of the season
and comparing that to a sort of more
conventional program aside Darcy and
we've seen no difference in the
performance just confirming the
observations that Donnie has had and
other growers have had around the region
and doing this sort of placement and
this year we're probably going to look
at more closely using it with the
brassicas with transplanted cabbage and
perhaps also with squash I'm not sure if
there's any growers in West in western
mass that are doing any work with the
deep place in um I don't think so you
guys are both using right yeah oh oh do
you play spin here oh can we ask the
growers there that are doing some zone
tells what their crop is and what is
their fertilizer program or how
going about it yes I'll hand you over to
Alan Zukowski first I used it on to curb
its in sweet corn and tobacco and i
apply banded fertilizer on the cucurbits
and sweet corn at planting time and then
I top press just before they run so most
of my fertilizers is close to the
surface slightly worked in and I don't
really see a problem that we get a few
rains the nitrogen leeches down to where
it needs to be and I've had really good
yields I'll hand it over to Wally we're
basically doing exactly the same thing
we use liquid fertilizer bandit when we
plant then we side dress with a LITTLEST
and cull avater and it's been working
fine and that was we I think we have 11
other grow okay sounds like the same
system all around and that was all ah
you said pumpkins I squash yes and sweet
coin alright how about on Long Island I
know we have some growers on Long Island
that are doing some zone tillage would
they care to share some of their
fertilizer approaches I I'd like to
reduce you using the slow release
fertilizer we haven't tried the deep
placement of the nitrogen but the last
two years have been using a 65-percent
ESN nitrogen that we've been pretty
happy with agree put that in planning
yeah so there's a quiet of planting and
what's the craw I've been using it on
our sweet corn and pumpkins
and I'm sorry I didn't hear the rate
then fallen recommends for the
respective crops oh all right any other
growers there that are doing some zone
tail that would like to share what their
approach has been with the particular
crop I knew we've always done we've put
down about I think it's about sixty
percent 10 10 10 in the soil next to the
plant and then I follow up later on in
the season with liquid nitrogen through
the drip irrigation system we have
worked with some slow release
fertilizers but we found that our soils
are cold so they don't release quick
enough so we need to change that so that
there's more available on the beginning
of the season because they get a slower
start okay anyone else from Long Island
I guess that's it okay um how about Jeff
I didn't know if any of your growers are
doing don't tell in your area that would
want to share some of their approaches
the people that have done zone till are
not here at the meeting today so we
don't really have anything to add
related to that I did have a question
for you I know first what he called what
are you consider deep placement how many
inches down and then are you using any
kind of nitrogen stabilizer I can just
speak to what we've been doing in our
trials and then we can ask I think then
Jim capron in western New York well
while we start with you Jim because I
know that you've worked with several
growers doing different configurations
so why you start I can make a loop
talking about things I was just in the
back of the room talking about
stabilizers and you know my theory on
nitrogen is that we really are going to
be putting it all on you know at or
before planning with the Ripper or the
stripper or the planner you know moaning
thiosulfate liquid night with you
liquid nitrogen with ammonium
thiosulfate is a very good way to go or
you know guardian or there's you know a
routine and some other you know
inhibitors and so forth and I think it
you know it's very very important that
we have it because the nitrogen is out
there hanging around for a long time we
can make it so it doesn't d 95 you know
it's Augie's all situations or bleach in
the liner gravel a sandy soil situations
I think that's very important to keep
our nitrogen where we want it when we
use that you know I call them happy
plants the car comes up green stays
green and never turns anything but dark
green you know for the whole growing
season including you know sweet corn
likely hand down and prevail so forth I
think it's real important for this
nitrogen management scenario to have
some inhibitor with it and that works
about six weeks I don't know 30 days or
so we'll take a short but you know in a
month's time or six weeks time we've got
the corn up the words going to begin to
take up nitrogen at a faster rate so
that anything that's reached a little
ways we can probably get at and bring it
back up with the roots of the plants but
you need some band and fertilizer to get
the plant through until it gets down
right I think the old standard
two-by-two fertilizer there ought to be
in a corn your field corn type situation
and I don't think that sweet cards much
different needs 30 to 40 pounds in the
fertilizer band to get that corn to me
high without me home its roots are a far
greater shape than at me I in order to
get in a deep place nitrogen or Daniel
to blend beside the risotto Coulter's
irregardless of tillage your regardless
of tillage meant the fertility deal is
the same with conventional or with zone
till the nitrogens got to be in the soil
where it ought to be positioned
correctly where it's not blended
throughout the whole soil soil profile
evenly everywhere
and what about infer all fertilizer
don't know too much you know in
fertilization you got to be really
careful with 721 7 or 9 18 9 or
something you know a couple gallons you
can I'll go along with the 10 gallons
I'm against because you're proud you've
run the risk of a stand establishment
problem with the seed and the tender
little seedlings but you can't get
enough fun like you would with a starter
right right too much nitrogen plus
piyush is where we get into trouble
especially if we put fertilizer in them
seed furrow under five gallons of acre
is you can twist my arm before you
anything over 3 i'm nervous so um as far
as when we've been using the deep placed
in and we've been going about eight
inches below the seed I don't know if
any growers have gone any shallower when
they're doing some transplants I think
John Altobelli was going six inches
below when he was transplanting cap
cauliflower as far as his placement of
nitrogen that's in our his results look
excellent he had a really great crop he
was really impressed with the
performance so is it is it better to say
stay at like six inches versus 10 for
most crops or well I guess some six to
eight I think eight inches is a good one
as a safe place to be and again that
would depend on your soil type I don't
10 inch is always just think any be
placed in in Long Island I'm sorry about
that you guys mean to cut you off deep
plays a dirty trick yep more than Long
Island I don't believe there's any one
there that's been doing it um any
Charles because of their sands and other
issues Long Island I think the nitrogen
needs to be placed behind the two
leading zone till Coulter's and that's
no such reasonably showers away from the
seed and seedling far enough and you
know it's away from the water table far
enough that
you know the plants can take up some
nitrogen that may 10 delete or move down
but D placed online right one is not
open to 10 inch has always sounded kind
of deep to me I've seen corn go through
a period of stress where it's waiting to
get to that nitrogen and I just always
wondered if with tomatoes and peppers
and things like that if you wouldn't be
better going like six inches so that
they don't go through that period of
stress right yep so that that's an
important part that banding when you're
planning your transplant and I think
they publish wanted a couple of the
years when we did the Charles with
Donnie we saw that that sweet corn stall
a little bit in the season early but it
did catch up very quickly so you may
observe that but we did recover I know
one of the advantages of if you do his
own tell properly which is to have
Coulter so you have fertilizer on both
sides of the row the old age of 100
pounds being maximum of n and k added
together you're you know that was when
we just put it on one side the damage is
on till with two Coulter's is you can
put all your fertilizer alongside the
roll up front but you're only putting
half of it on each side you're not
putting it all in one place and you get
away with it as opposed to 40 years ago
when they said you couldn't put over a
hundred pounds and they were only they
were just talking about one band so with
zone tillage you get two bands if you
put them about two and a half inches on
each side and just about the seed depth
or so you're in good shape but it's a
vertical blend with two halters putting
it down you already get a half the rate
but you have a vertical blend from
basically from zero done yep five or six
inches deep however the Coulter's are
going and I call that it's bathed with
nitrogen the roots of the seedling yucca
go any direction they want they're going
to find some daikaiju I put some dry on
to a 20 / 20 i broadcast 200 pounds of
that before I do anything
then I have the side dress why put on
with the corn planter then I I band my
broadcast my nitrogen with my herbicide
which has been the best combination i've
had yet i mean as far as the results of
the corn in everything else so um at
this point i wanted to just open it up
for any more questions i did want to
come do we have any other questions from
here in ithaca nope um then we we didn't
spend and less much time talking about
your equipment setup and i didn't know
there were questions about the system
that you use since i wanted to make sure
we got back to that i'm going to try to
i'll try to put that picture yes ya know
we had we had one more fertility
question here in Massachusetts great go
ahead hi I'm wondering if anybody has
worked with using compost and getting
that worked in with the zone builder
we've used to speak to what we've done
this is on you again in Ithaca and um in
some of our Charles we do also do
experiments doing so intelligent organic
systems and so that's always been a
concern for us and so we have generally
been broadcasting that compost over the
top early in the spring and then we are
just using the zone building to
incorporate in the area but another
thing we have done is band with compost
like a poultry compost a very fine
compost in some cases we've had to go in
and we've used that as a band
application in those cases in our
glandular plot yeah otherwise we're just
we've just broadcast it and then we just
work it in with the zone tail and then
we move our zone the strip's where we're
building every year we're not in the
same area all the time so we are working
that in and when your banding are you
managing to apply with the zone building
operation or are you doing that ahead of
time oh that would be afterwards after
week plan and we actually
sort of band any other one anyone else
have experience with using compost in a
zone till system I think yo was a few
growers here I've worked with I got a
plant you know working this compost in
with an airway is certainly one way to
get the compost worked in which is a
couple top six inches of the soil but
we've also had experience with his
religion pelleted chicken manure going
through regular dry fertilizer openers
and that gets quite a bit of fertility
20 right down road up to be only 34
inches dtronics oil it's not too far to
see isn't that you know Criers chicken
manure pellets does an excellent job for
the organic folks it's expensive for a
pound of nitrogen bought but it get
dresses that fertility issue in the
organic situation pretty well another
approach that we've used this is on
again is putting compost on in the fall
just prior to seating a cover crop and
so we do a little bit of shallow surface
tillage at that point prior to seeding a
cover crop to work in our car so that's
I think another good strategy for
incorporating a compost into its own
tool system what's that um so any other
questions before we kind of go back and
spend a little bit more time with Dan
and looking at her unit to see if we've
got any more questions about that or